Jenny's story is truly amazing, and we're
going to hear from her later in the lesson.
>> She talked a lot about passing on the trait of dwarfism
or achondroplasia to her children, and for us to understand exactly what
that entails, we need to think about what's actually getting passed down
to the next generation. So how's the whole genome involved in this process?
>> Well, let's take a moment and step back from our pedigree. So,
focus on the physical material. That's
actually passed down from generation to generation.
>> So, you're talking about DNA.
>> Right. DNA. The genetic material that
a parent passes on, to their offspring. Tell
me. What cell type is most responsible
for passing DNA on to, the next generation?